are you ready to learn a bunch of
secrets and easter eggs about aaron
jaeger that you probably didn't know of
course you are let's get started aaron
ranks second in the first character
popularity poll right after levi
ackerman as we all know aaron is a
really energetic character this is why
isayama chose to give him black hair so
that it would be easier to draw speed
lines around him when he is moving we
usually get to see only one titan form
for each character but when it comes to
aaron we got to see a total of seven
different forms this includes pure titan
form incomplete titan failed titan
attack titan attack plus warhammer titan
founding titan and colossal titan in the
past isayama stated that he struggled to
make aaron feel alive when writing this
is why he called him a slave to the
story because of this isayama stated
that he didn't expect aaron to be
popular with readers however he also
said that aaron ranking second in the
character popularity pool really
surprised him aaron's titan form is
based on the japanese martial artist
yushinokami the creator of the attack on
titan also said that it is the ideal
physique of a middleweight mixed martial
artist aaron's fighting style is based
on a completely different fighter named
takanorigomi isayama used his southpaw
fighting style as a model for aaron the
name aaron is of turkish origin its
exact meaning and description are he who
progresses has reached towards divinity
maturity and sacred wisdom it can also
be interpreted as a saint or holy person
aaron could also stand for the german
word eri which means honor isayama has
stated that part of the reason he chose
the name aaron for the character is that
it sounds feminine which would make it
easier to remember aaron's surname
jaeger is an anglicized form of the
german surname jaeger meaning hunter
isayama said that he was skeptical about
the importance of bloodlines when coming
up with aaron this is why he made him
someone not blessed with natural talent
and the exact opposite of an ordinary
talented protagonist aaron's name is
believed to have come from his father's
compatriot aaron kruger he also uses his
last name kruger when he pretends to be
an injured soldier while infiltrating
marley isayama has stated he paid
particular attention to aaron's eyes
when designing him in order to make him
stand out from the rest of the cast in
addition he specifically chose to give
aaron thin eyebrows instead of thick
ones because he felt it would be
artificial to try to use thicker
eyebrows to accent aaron's angry
personality aaron has the highest titan
kill record by far out of all the former
graduates of the 104th training corps he
has killed only one titan in his human
form with the odm gear and around 22
with the help of his titan abilities
this makes his kill count around 23
although he probably killed many more
offscreen according to isayama if the
104th training court did have an arm
wrestling competition aaron would be
evenly matched with gene an interview
with isayama's editor back in 2013
revealed that isa yama originally
intended for aaron to know that he was a
titan from the very beginning however he
later scratched this idea since it would
make the show less interesting in the
online game age of gunslingers a special
titan mode was made to tribute the
series it features elm an npc modeled
after aaron and voiced by yuki kaji
there's also a special skin for the dual
pistol class available for purchase now
let's talk about a small detail that
almost everyone missed in this one scene
aaron was seen holding some kind of sign
if we zoom in a bit we can clearly see
that it says subscribe to jaegerists i
don't know why aaron would hold
something like that but it's probably
best that you do exactly what he tells
you you don't want to piss off aaron
towards the end of attack on titan aaron
grows out his hair when an interviewer
asked isayama why he did this he said
quote right now he is in a state where
he is no longer paying attention to how
people view him so he just lets it grow
out he should have kept a cleaner
hairstyle since he was supposed to be a
hospitalized patient referring to the
time aaron infiltrated marley okay this
fact is the most hilarious one yet the
titan forms of various attack on titan
characters were censored in malaysia the
titan forms of aaron as well as annie
and many more were seen wearing black
undergarments they literally put pants
on the titans after seeing this fans
started to make many memes and edit
themselves it's hilarious on a serious
note i got a very important question for
you guys if aaron's founding titan form
wore pants how would he wear them i'm
probably leaning towards this answer but
definitely tell me what you think in the
comments hajime isayama said that he
does not see aaron and armin as best
friends forever this proved true after
aaron accused armin of being controlled
by berthold and through their fight
after aaron declared he always hated
mikasa aaron learned something really
important from levi and no we're not
talking about military tactics levi
taught him how to clean according to
captain's expert judgment aaron was the
best at cleaning out of all the cadets
the attack on titan's unique ability to
see the future made aaron depressed
since he knows how horrifying the end
will be for everyone involved he loses
all hope additionally he's aware of the
divide between the eldians themselves
both of whom view others as enemies
instead of friends the story of the
attack on titan gets really dark as time
goes on so here's one small detail to
remember the good old times back in
episode 1 while carla and aaron were
talking carla immediately knew that
aaron was lying she knew this right away
because aaron's ears turn red whenever
he's lying in the 104th training court
aaron's nickname was actually the
suicide blockhead in season one of the
show when aaron was tasked with plugging
the hole in the wall rose he was seen
carrying a large boulder on his
shoulders this was inspired by the
ancient greek titan atlas he carried a
celestial sphere in his arms aaron's
birthday is on march 30th making him in
aries aaron is the character who gets in
trouble all the time throughout the
series so it shouldn't come as a shock
to learn that he was kidnapped a total
of three times on the show both aarons
and grisha's attack titans have pointy
ears however considering that aaron
krueger's attack titan does not have
this feature we can assume it's
something unique only to the jaeger
family aaron's height went from 170
centimeters to 183 centimeters in season
four making him one of the 104th
graduates that grew the most in height i
hope levi doesn't hear about this there
have been multiple inspirations that
hajime isayama has taken from various
mythical stories and folklores however
this has never been officially confirmed
by the creator himself there are a lot
of similarities between a protagonist
erin yeager and another popular
fictional character the character is
ericos from eternal champion eternal
champion is a 1970 novel by michael
morcock ericos and aaron start by
wanting to save the world yet end up
being its very enemy isayama stated in
an interview that because he and aaron
are polar opposites he had a hard time
writing the character until around the
fourth volume of the manga he also
claimed that he could not truly
understand aaron's character until he
heard yuki kaji's portrayal of him
during aaron's long battle against
annie's female titan aaron gets defeated
while annie makes her escape in order to
catch her aaron entered into so-called
berserk mode prompting veins in his
titan body to glow bright red giving him
extra strength and power he could easily
pin annie's titan down and defeat her
with his power well you're probably
wondering what is the fact here everyone
knew this already well the thing that
most people didn't know is that this
berserk mode is an exclusive anime scene
and never happened in the manga as a
matter of fact this whole fight played
out a little differently in the manga so
you definitely want to check that out if
you didn't know in the original attack
on titan manga aaron transforms into his
titan form under the stage of willy's
tiber festival he then throws him in the
air instantly splitting his body in half
this same scene was slightly different
in the anime because the creators
thought it was way too explicit also
during aaron's battle with warhammer
titan his titan gets decapitated and his
body is covered in smoke censoring it in
the manga things are very different and
there are way more explicit images in
the 2013 blog post isa yama revealed
that he had selected otoko hua romandase
takedakun as a character song for aaron
due to copyright reasons i'm not going
to play the song here but if you're
interested go and check it out click on
this video where we explain all the
founding titans in attack on titan why
are you still here click it